[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Superman Batman Wonder Woman these are
some of the greatest Titans of DC Comics
the world has come to a door over the
past 80 years especially as they made
the leap from page to Silver Screen and
TV in the 50s and 60s you'll find them
all in our guide to every DC Comics
movie ranked by Tomato Meter but the
world of comic book publishing is
nothing if not vast a constellation of
multiverses retcons annuals and imprints
moving beyond the strictly superhero
element of DC Comics this guide will
also feature the adapted works from DC
imprint vertigo like V for Vendetta and
Paradox press which made a history of
violence
how come
so good
at killing people we've limited the
movies to theatrical releases only which
does keep out the home animated Fair
like the DC adaptations but to that end
you will find Return of the cape
Crusaders here which got a one day
theatrical release so great leaping
catfish this introduction is now over
hurry let's count down every DC movie
ranked by Tomato Meter
[Music]
thank you number 10 Superman 2. Superman
foils the plot of terrorists by hurtling
their nuclear device into outer space
but the bombshock waves free the
Kryptonian villain General Zod and his
henchmen Ursa and Nan from their
imprisonment traveling to Earth they
threaten the planet with destruction and
at the same time Superman decides to
renounce his superpowers in order to
live a normal life as Clark Kent with
his new love Lois Lane starring
Christopher Reeve Gene Hackman Margot
Kidder and directed by Richard Lester
critics say the humor occasionally
stumbles into slapstick territory and
the special effects are dated but
Superman 2 meets if not exceeds the
standard set by its predecessor son of
jorel
we were beginning to think you were a
coward I'm not a coward dog
let him prove it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
then die as you deserve to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Superman kill him is gonna be good
take him
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the big one's just as strong as Superman
number nine A History of Violence
when a pair of petty criminals attempt
to Rob his Small Town Diner Tom Stahl
quickly and easily kills them both in
the flesh of news coverage of Tom's
seemingly heroic actions a threatening
stranger named Carl Fogarty comes to
town figuring the unassuming family man
as long missing Philadelphia mobster
Joey Cusack to the horror of his wife
and teenage son Tom must confront his
violent past starring Viggo Mortensen
Maria Bello Ed Harris and directed by
David Cronenberg critics say A History
of Violence raises compelling and
thoughtful questions about the nature of
violence while representing a return to
form for director David Cronenberg in
one of his more uncharacteristic pieces
[Music]
you're coming to the house who's coming
to the house just grab it dude hey stop
are you serious I'll be there soon as I
can
[Music]
come on
come on
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
come on
Tom
number eight The Dark Knight Rises it
has been eight years since Batman in
collusion with Commissioner Gordon
vanished into the night assuming
responsibility for the death of Harvey
Dent Batman sacrificed everything for
what he and Gordon hoped would be the
greater good however the arrival of a
cunning cat burglar and a merciless
terrorist named Bane forced Batman out
of Exile into a battle he may not be
able to win starring Christian Bale Gary
Oldman Anne Hathaway and directed by
Christopher Nolan critics say The Dark
Knight Rises is an ambitious thoughtful
and potent action film that concludes
Christopher Nolan's franchise in
spectacular fashion
pain
let's not stand on ceremony here
Mr Wayne
Jesus Christ
victory has defeated you
laughs
foreign
number seven the Lego Batman movie there
are big changes brewing in Gotham but if
Batman wants to save the city from the
Joker's hostile takeover he may have to
drop the long vigilante thing try to
work with others and maybe just maybe
learn to lighten up maybe a superhero
sidekick Robin and loyal Butler Alfred
can show him a thing or two starring
Will Arnett Michael Sarah Zach
Galifianakis and directed by Chris McKay
critics say the Lego Batman movie
continues its Blockbuster franchise's
winning streak with another round of
dizzyingly funny and beautifully
animated family-friendly Mayhem oh look
at all these do I get a costume for the
mission too I got a feeling that you'll
just look like a kid on Halloween don't
you think don't touch them
[Music]
oh
how do we feel about this one dress-up
parties are for grown-ups only wait
what's that one there oh that one was
for the assignment called the Jamaica
Caper the locals called me regimon I
love it ah it feels like I was poured
into this my only trouble is
pants are just a little tight I don't
know if I could throw a kick or jump in
them I got an idea rip that's better now
I'm free now I'm moving come on Batman
let's get groovin I could only eyes
right now
number six Shazam
we all have a superhero inside of us it
just takes a bit of magic to bring it
out in 14 year old Billy Batson's case
all he needs to do is shout out one word
to transform into the adult superhero
Shazam still a kid at heart Shazam
Revels in the new version of himself by
doing what any other teen would do have
fun while testing out his Newfound
Powers but he'll need to master them
quickly before the evil Dr Thaddeus
monic and get his hands on shazam's at
magical abilities starring Zachary Levi
Mark Strong Jack Dylan Grazer and
directed by David F Sandberg critics say
an effortlessly entertaining blend of
humor and heart Shazam is a superhero
movie that never forgets the genre's
real power joyous wish fulfillment
gentlemen why use guns when we can
handle this like real men
Betty look out
bullet immunity you have bullet immunity
Bulletproof
today is December 8th and this is video
proof of authenticity
shoot him again oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah go both of you come on go to town
bye-bye we still don't know if the suit
is bulletproof or if you are
shoot him in the face in the face
that kind of tickles
you're dead
sorry about your window you're welcome
for not getting robbed hey
to fighting bad guys
Teen Titans Go
major superheroes out there starring in
their own movies all but the Teen Titans
Robin is bound and determined to remedy
that situation by becoming a star
instead of a sidekick with a few mad cap
ideas and a song in their hearts the
Teen Titans head to Hollywood to fulfill
their dreams things go awry however when
a super villain plans to take over the
planet putting the very fate of the
young Heroes on the line starring Greg
Sipes Scott Menville Tara Strong and
directed by Peter Rita Michael and Aaron
Horvath critics say Teen Titans go to
the movies to Stills the enduring appeal
of its colorful characters into a
charmingly light-hearted adventure whose
wacky humor fuels its infectious fun and
Belize a surprising level of
intelligence
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
now you're wasting everybody's time
we'll stop you Slade how are you gonna
do it how are you gonna beat me you
haven't done it yet you keep talking
about how you're gonna do it what are
you gonna do you're gonna fart on me you
wanna dance off you're gonna annoy me to
death with your waffles
you guys are jokes total jokes
you're right
we are jokes we're not like the other
superheroes never will be but
but the thing is that's okay let's I'm
proud to call myself a Teen Titan and so
are my friends yes so laugh at us all
you want but we're still going to take
you down
number four Wonder Woman
before she was Wonder Woman she was
Diana princess of the Amazons trained to
be an unconquerable Warrior raised on a
sheltered Island Paradise Diana meets an
American pilot who tells her about the
massive conflict that's raging in the
outside world convinced that she can
stop the threat Diana leaves her home
for the first time fighting alongside
men in a war to end all wars she finally
discovers her full powers and true
destiny starring Gal Gadot Chris Pine
Connie Nielsen and directed by Patty
Jenkins critics say thrilling Earnest
and buoyed by gal gadot's charismatic
performance Wonder Woman succeeds in
spectacular fashion
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
let's move
foreign
[Music]
number three Batman Return of the caved
Crusaders Batman and Robin have their
hands full when penguin The Joker
Riddler and Catwoman combine their
nefarious talents to threaten Gotham
City starring Adam West Stephen Weber
Julie Newmar and directed by Rick
Morales critics say Adam West's groovy
interpretation of the cape Crusader
returns in a new medium popping in the
realm of animation with the harassable
energy of an exclamation accented
onomatopoeia poor people have it rich
people need it if you eat it you die
what is it nothing I can't come up with
anything either Batman no Chief the
answer is nothing
how can nothing be a clue when it's not
even a thing in this case nothing is
certainly something Robin let's see Zero
zilch goose egg precisely farmer Jones
delivered a shipment of his
prize-winning goose eggs to the local
market just last week thereafter eggs
it's not what was delivered commissioner
rather when last Tuesday which was also
the night of the total lunar eclipse you
say it's really quite simple the atomic
energy laboratory headed by our old
friend Professor Nichols just opened a
new Wing dedicated to the science of
total lunar eclipses and I'll bet my
cowl the Laboratories where those
felonious fiends are going to strike
next of course how could I not see it
myself come on Robin there's a bad moon
on the rise
to the Batmobile
[Music]
that's what we do without him
commissioner I shot her to even consider
it Ohara
number two Superman the movie
just before the destruction of the
Planet Krypton scientist jorel sends his
infant son Cal L on a spaceship to Earth
raised by kindly Farmers Jonathan and
Martha Kent young Clark discovers the
source of his superhuman powers and
moves to Metropolis to fight evil as
Superman he battles the villainous Lex
Luthor while as novice reporter Clark
Kent he attempts to woo co-worker Lois
Lane starring Marlon Brando Christopher
Reeve Gene Hackman and directed by
Richard Donner critics say Superman
definitely Blends humor and gravitas
taking advantage of the perfectly cast
Christopher Reeve to craft a loving
nostalgic tribute to an American pop
culture icon
foreign
[Music]
excuse me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
easy Miss I've got you you've got me
who's got you
I can't believe it I just I just cannot
believe it he got her
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
Watchmen in an alternate 1985 America
costume superheroes are part of everyday
life when one of its former comrades is
murdered Mass vigilante Rorschach
uncovers a plot to kill and discredit
all past and present superheroes as he
reconnects with his retired Associates
only one of which has true Powers
Rorschach glimpses a far-reaching
conspiracy involving their shared past
and catastrophic consequences for the
world's future starring Billy crudup
Jeffrey Dean Morgan malen Ackerman and
directed by Zack Snyder critics say
gritty and visually striking Watchman is
a faithful adaptation of Alan Moore's
graphic novel but its complex narrative
structure may make it difficult for it
to appeal to viewers not already
familiar with the source material
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Batman
having witnessed his parents brutal
murder as a child millionaire
philanthropist Bruce Wayne fights crime
in Gotham City disguised as Batman a
costume hero who strikes fear into the
hearts of villains but when a deformed
madman who calls himself The Joker
seizes control of Gotham's criminal
underworld Batman must face his most
ruthless Nemesis ever while protecting
both his identity and his love interest
reporter Vicki Vale starring Michael
Keaton Jack Nicholson Kim Basinger and
directed by Tim Burton critics say an
eerie haunting spectacle Batman succeeds
as dark entertainment even if Jack
Nicholson's Joker too often overshadows
the title character
[Music]
Jesus
[Music]
let him go around to Gordon
[Music]
nice outfit
[Music]
V for Vendetta following World War
London is a police state occupied by a
fascist government and a vigilante known
as V uses terrorist tactics to fight the
oppressors of the world in which he now
lives when V saves Evie from the secret
police he discovers an ally in his fight
against England's oppressors starring
Natalie Portman Hugo weaving Steven Raya
and directed by James mcteague critics
say visually stunning and
thought-provoking V for Vendetta's
political pronouncements May rile some
but its story and impressive set pieces
will nevertheless entertain
thank you
hello Evie
it was you
yeah
that wasn't real
I'm sorry but Mr dietrich's dead
I thought they'd arrest him but when
they found a Quran in his house they had
him executed
[Music]
fortunately I got to you before they did
he caught them
here
he taught me
you tortured me
why
you said you wanted to live without fear
I wish there'd been any easier way but
there wasn't oh my God
and finally number one The Dark Knight
with the help of allies Lieutenant Jim
Gordon and D.A Harvey Dent Batman has
been able to keep a tight lid on crime
in Gotham City but when a vile young
criminal calling himself The Joker
suddenly throws a town into chaos the
Kate Crusader begins to try to find line
between heroism and vigilantism starring
Christian Bale Heath Ledger Maggie
Gyllenhaal and directed by Christopher
Nolan critics say dark complex and
Unforgettable The Dark Knight succeeds
not just as an entertaining comic book
film but as a richly thrilling crime
Saga I know why you're afraid to go out
at night
the Batman
you see Batman has shown Gotham to your
true colors unfortunately
Dan he's just the beginning
and and as for uh the televisions
so-called plan Batman has no
jurisdiction he'll find him and make him
squeal I know the Squealers when I see
them and
put your purpose it's simple we uh kill
the Batman
if it's so simple why haven't you done
it already if you're good at something
never do it for free
how much you want
uh half
you're crazy
no I'm not
if we don't deal with this now
soon
little uh Gamble here won't be able to
get a nickel for his grandma enough from
the clouds
let's not blow this out of proportion
you think you could steal from us and
just walk away yeah I'm putting the word
out 500 grand for this clown dead a
million alive so I can teach them some
manners first
all right so listen why don't you give
me a call when you want to start taking
things a little more seriously here's my
card
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love and
for even more news scores and
recommendations on the latest TV shows
and movies head on over to
rottentomatoes.com until next time I'm
your host Naz Perez and we'll see you
back here for more top tens on the
Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]